[Musique]
moi j'ai toujours voulu avoir un café
depuis chez petit c'est comme ça
toujours été mon rêve je t'engage à
brooke avec cette idée en tête je
tenterais ma technique car en gestion de
commerces si c'est à ce moment là que
j'ai vu cet épisode sur le danois de
copenhague au danemark bienne à
l'épicerie copenhague ville
multiculturelle de plus d'un million
d'habitants que l'ont dit parmi les plus
heureux de la planète très verte la
ville fait une grande place aux
cyclistes il y a d'ailleurs plus de
vélos que d'auto sur son territoire ça
m'a amené beaucoup de questions à propos
de ces pays-là propos de leur culture
surtout j'avais tant au kg partant en
voyage par la suite au danemark en suède
et en norvège je suis parti en pack sac
je fais pousser couch surfing pour
essayer le plus possible de rencontrer
les gens là bas puis de m'imprégner de
leur culture et de leur manière de voir
la vie puis j'ai ramené le plus possible
de culture là avec moi
[Musique]
l'attaquant no 24 mois et j'ai d'abord
1,4 à ses tons café
c'est quoi qui vient en tête l'image que
me définit ce que tu as pu ramener deux
autres petits morceaux c'est vraiment de
prendre le temps de savourer la vie
c'est vraiment
d'accorder sa vie selon les moments
quand même moment présent et savoureux
il faut prendre le temps de s'arrêter
puis de le savourer en vedette cette
semaine le bugue c'est un mot danois qui
décrit une sensation de bien-être et de
cannes par exemple boire un chocolat
chaud sur le bord d'un feux après une
journée plein air en hiver c'est très
rude j'aurais voulu avec cette idée du
gain qui est le réconfort danois qui mon
but ce n'est pas de récréer exactement
leur culture ici medhat happy days les
réconforts danois un autre réalité ici à
notre culture
qu'est-ce que tu gardes et finalement
qu'est-ce qui fonctionne depuis dégradée
laisse membres mais justement les
scellés sont nombreux à sortir les gens
de leur zone de confort
le les crottes de garder sauce express
de de porridge et c'est un mélange de
crevaisons qu'on fait avec de si tu
cries anti qu'une ampoule est 6e avec
qui apple qui fait
[Musique]
en
mais l'ultime hughes c'est le goal
version danoise de notre bon vieux gruau
certains restaurants en font même leur
spécialité jeunes constitue ici c'est le
guet trempé dans le sirop d'érable est
vraiment
très
bon